there is a Eureka moment that happened
early on in in the work that Novick and
I were doing he isolated the first
mutant and he could see using simple
assays that the enzymes that normally
are secreted outside of the ESL in his
mutant now build up inside the cell but
the most dramatic moment came when he
looked using the electron microscope at
sections of the cell and he called
excitedly up to my office from down in
the basement where the electron
microscope was and I went down and I had
a look and it was you know revelation to
see a cell that ordinarily has only a
sort of sparse collection of organelles
but which instead in this mutant hat it
was just dying of overload of the
vesicles that were being produced but
couldn't be delivered to the cell
surface and so the cell has is just
accumulates with lots of vesicles and
that was you know that one image stands
in my mind as that is really the
beginning of my career and I knew from
that moment that I would be consumed for
at least the next 20 years trying to
figure it all out and so that was really
a lucky break